you know this is not this is not the way
to have a conversation if you want to
have a conversation you're welcome to
come talk to me you can sit here okay
right you're going you're going to
you're going to wait for me right please
I don't I do not believe you I listen to
you and I will respond I do not believe
you respectfully I do not believe you
fact of the matter is that the American
people's voice are what need to be heard
because because our president is not
speaking for the American people and
neither are you that's your opinion
that's your opinion yes that's my
opinion but well then sit down we've
heard your opinion thank you very much
for once I actually believe Hillary this
this man seems incredulous that Hillary
will stick around and wait for him
afterwards I think she's going to wait
for him I think she's this man is
definitely going to see Hillary again
you know I'm really sorry to hear about
this man's imminent suicide I am not
suicidal Hillary Clinton gold parallel
rookie card